اعلن فئران الافراج عن ثلاثه مليارات
دولار من الارصده الايرانيه المجمده في
العراق بفعل العقوبات الامريكيه واتات
الخطوه بعيده في ايران انباء عن قرب
توصلها الى اتفاق مع الولايات المتحده
يقضي برفع بعض العقوبات مقابل فرض قيود
على برنامجها النووي واشدد الطيران على
انه لا يوجد اتفاق معقد بديل للاتفاق
النووي على جدول الاعمال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم رفع التجميد
عن مليارات الدولارات الايرانيه وهل يمكن
ربط ذلك مباشره باي انفراجه في ملف اعاده
احياء الاتفاق النووي ما محوريه ملف
الاموال المجمده الايرانيه في مفاوضات
التواصل الاتفاق ايراني غربي وما الذي
تعنيه الحلحله المتدرجه لملفات التفاوض
خصوصا بعد الاعلان عن توافق ايراني مع
وكاله طاقه الذريه وتفاهمات في ملف الاسرع
ما النتائج التي قد تترتب على هذه الخطوه
ومنعكاسات التوافق الامريكي الايراني
اقليميا ودوليا وفق السيناريو المطروح
بالتوصل للاتفاق محدود ومؤقت
[موسيقى]
رغم مصارعه كل من واشنطن وطهران الى نفي
ان يكون هناك اتفاق قريب بشان الملف
النووي الايراني مثلا الافراج عن ارصده
ايرانيه كانت مجمده لدى العراق بفعل
عقوبات امريكيه ماده لتخمينات حول دلالات
الخطوه وما قد تقود اليها تقارير ايرانيه
كانت قد قالت الثلاثاء ان طهران ستحصل
قريبا على 24 مليار دولار من ارصدتها
المجمده في الخارج وقالت وسائل اعلام
ايرانيه محليه ان سبعه مليارات دولار لدى
كوريا الجنوبيه ستكون بين المبالغ المفرج
عنها واشارت وسائل الاعلام المحليه تلك
الى ان عشره مليارات دولار ستكون مقدار ما
سيتم الافراج عنه من العراق هذا عدا عن
قرابه سبعه مليارات دولار قد تحصل عليها
ايران قريبا كمستحقات لصالحها بفضل
مفاوضات بينها وصندوق النقد الدولي
كانت طهران قد اعلنت في ابريل نيسان من
العام الماضي الافراج عن جزء كبير من
الارصده الايرانيه المجمده بعد التوصل
للاتفاق مستقل عن الاتفاق النووي
[موسيقى]
لمناقصه هذا الموضوع معنا من طهران حسين
روي وران البحث المختص في القضايا
الاقليميه والاستراتيجيه ومن واشنطن
الدكتور جوزيف سيرين سيوني عضو سابق
بالمجلس للاستشاري لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وكبير الباحثين في معهد كوينسي
سيد جوزيف ابدا معك ظاهريا هذه الاموال
المفرزه عنها هي بطلب عراقي لدفع مستحقات
لايران هل تنتهي القصه عند هذا الحد
سؤال ممتاز وطابه مسائكم جميعا انتم
والمشاهدين هذه الصفقه لها مغزاها بحد
ذاتها لان العراق كان مدينا بهذا المال
ايران لانه يشتري الغاز والكهرباء وهو
مدين لايران باثنين فاصله سبعه مليار
دولار ولم يستطع دفعها بسبب العقوبات
الامريكيه فناشد العراق الوقت المتحده
لتوافق على اطلاق هذا المبلغ وقد يكون هذا
هو كل ما في الامر وينتهي الامر عند هذا
العراق يحتاج الى الغاز الى الكهرباء
فيدفع ثمنه لكن كان هناك الكثير من
النشاطات الاسابيع القليله الماضيه نعلم
انه كانت هناك لقاءات مع الايرانيين
والمبعوث الخاص امريكي روبوت مالي وكان
هناك حديث عن اتفاق انتقالي نعرف ان كان
هناك لقاءات في عمان بين مسؤولين من
الطرفين وهو احد مسؤوليه المكتب المستشار
القومي الارسال الامن القومي والحديث دار
عن احتمال اطلاق سبعه مليارات من
الدولارات تحت جزها كوريا الجنوبيه
بالامكاننا نعتبر هذا الاتفاق جزءا من
اتفاق اكبر بسبب الكثير من النقاشات
والتدخلات لان امرا ما يبدو وكانه يحدث
فعلا طيب قبل ما اعود للسيد حسين ما طبيعه
هذا الاتفاق وما شكله برايك يعني هل يمكن
فهم الافراج عن هذه الاموال بمعزل عن ما
تحدثت عنه من لقاءات تجري وحديث عن اتفاق
مؤقت
بالامكان ان نفسره بمعزل عن كل شيء اخر
وهنا تفسير منطقي كافي لذلك لان ايران
بدات
بوقف جزئيا ما يحتاجه العراق من موارد
الطاقه والعراق يحتاج الى ذلك اذا هناك
مغزى بحد ذات هذا الامر لكن ربما هو ايضا
بادره حسن
نيه من الولايات المتحده ايران لا تثق
بالله المتحده والاسباب وجيهه ونحن لا نثق
بهم ايضا ربما قد يكون هذا سبيلا الى
المزيد من التعاملات لان مثلا كوريا
الجنوبيه تفرج عن سبعه مليارات دولار
تحتجزها او قد تكون مبادره حسن
نيه للتوصل الى اتفاق حول تخصيب
الايرانيوم هذا ما يدور الحديث حوله هنا
في واشنطن سيد حسين كيف تفهم انت الافراج
عن هذه الاموال المجمده هل هي بمعزل عن ما
يجري من محادثات يتم الكشف عنها من قبل
بعض المواقع والحديث عن اتفاق مؤقت ام
انها جزء من صفقه اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي لك ولضيفي
الكريم والمشاهدين الاعزاء يعني في تصوري
ان هناك خطه جيم تنفذ على ارض الواقع يمكن
ان
نتلمسها من خلال سلوكيات
تحدث خلال الشهر الاخير يعني الخطه الف هي
مفاوضات فينه وصلت الى طريق مسدود الخطه
الخطه العسكريه ضد ايران ايضا هي دخلت
يعني في ازمه الخطه جيم هي
التزامات
من الطرفين جزئيه متقابله من دون اعلان
ومن دون توقيع يعني لا يمكن ان نفهم لماذا
التزمت ايران مع الوكاله الدوليه بالتعاون
في امور معينه لماذا تم اطلاق سراح
السجناء لماذا الان اطلاق افراج عن ثلاثه
مليار دولار لماذا السيد ماكرون اليوم
ساعه ونصف يتكلم مع السيد رئيسي يعني هذا
لا يمكن ان نفهمه الا ضمن اطار ما اسميه
انا الخطه جيم الخطه جيم هو الالتزامات
المتبادله ايران التزمت امام الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رغم النفي الذي
يجري من الطرفين
في المقابل هناك افراج عن اموال قد يكون
تخفيض لمستوى
التخصيب في المقابل تحدث انفراجات جديده
وقد تكون هناك خطوات جديده
يكون الطرف الاوروبي هو الطرف الاساسي في
تنفيذها يعني امريكا الان
لا تستطيع ان ترفع العقوبات المصرفيه
والاقتصاديه ولكن اوروبا تريد رفع هذه
العقوبات ولكن تخاف من عقوبات ثانويه من
قبل امريكا هناك بشكل او باخر اخراج لهذا
الموضوع يعني كما راينا في العراق هذا
الاحراج جاء بالطلب من الحكومه العراقيه
اوروبا قد تكون تطلب من الحكومه الامريكيه
جزء من العقوبات نعم اريد ان اسال عنه شكل
الخطوات الجديده التي يمكن ان تتخذها
اوروبا او ان تقوم بها اوروبا
يعني اتصور اول شيء مطلوب ايرانيا هو
المنصه الماليه ان تمتلك ايران منصه من
خلال الاوروبيين للقيام بكل العمليات
الماليه المصرفيه على المستوى الدولي
العقوبات الثانويه الامريكيه هي التي كانت
تمنع الاوروبيين ولكن في تصوري امام
الحلحله التي تحدث الان هناك اراده
امريكيه في التغاضي عن بعض الامور وقد
يكون هذا مطروح اوروبيا وفي تصوري ان
المكالمه الطويله بين الرئيس ماكرون
والرئيس رئيسي هي تاتي ضمن اطار ان يلعب
الطرف الاوروبي دورا اساسيا في هذه
الالتزامات المتقابله طيب نقطه اخيره لو
سمحت لو ساعود الى السيد جوزيف تحدثت عن
ان رغم ان الجانبين
ينفيان ذلك بتقديرك لماذا تنفي
ايران الى حد اليوم وجود اي اتفاق مؤقت
على الرغم من كل الاشارات التي تحدثت عنها
يعني في تصوري ان هناك احراج لدى الطرفين
يعني ايران تقول
يجب ان تعود امريكا الى الاتفاق عام 2015
امريكا تقول العوده لهذا الاتفاق مستحيل
ايران تقول رفع كامل لكل العقوبات ضمن
اطار مفاوضات فيينا وهذا
لا تنازل عن هذا السقف امريكا تحت ضغط
اللوبي الصهيوني في امريكا لا تستطيع ان
تعود للاتفاق كل هذا الظرف الضاغط على
الطرفين تم التنفيس عنه من خلال خطه بديله
وخطوات عمليه على الارض بعيدا عن اي توقيع
او التزام
علني من قبل الطرفين سيد جوزيف اذا كانت
هذه هي الاسباب التي تجعل ايران تنفي
واتفاق مؤقت ما الذي يدفع
بواشنطن لنفي وجود اي اتفاق مؤقت هل لان
هذا الاتفاق لم يتحقق بعد ام خوفا من ان
يؤدي شيئا الى عرقله هذا الاتفاق ما دوافع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في عدم
الاعلان عنه
اولهما حسب ما نفهم الامور بافضل صيغه انه
لا يوجد هناك اتفاق حتى الان افضل ما تم
التوصل اليه واتفاق مؤقت اولي توصل اليه
الفريقان المفاوضان ثم ارسل كل فريق الخطه
الى عاصمته لنيل الموافقات طبعا هذه مرحله
جديده كلنا شعرنا ان الاتفاق الذي تم
التوصل اليه في سبتمبر الماضي كان خطه
جائزه لكن الحكومه الايرانيه رفضته فلم
يكن هناك اتفاق وكما يقول زميلي من ايران
الولايات المتحده ايضا متردده في الاعلان
اي اتفاق لانهم لا يريدون
تلقي النقد السياسي الذي والضغط السياسي
والرفض
هنا في واشنطن وفي اسرائيل وربما في بلدان
اخرى اذا القانون الاساسي للمتفاوضين هو
التزموا الصمت حتى توصل الى اتفاق كامل ثم
بعد ذلك نتحدث عن
اشرت الى موضوع اسرائيل وكذلك فعل السيد
حسين لا تخفى الاسرائيل ابدا عن تطورات
العلاقات الايرانيه الامريكيه ولها فيما
يتعلق بملف طهران النووي مصادر
تكررها او مصادره تكررها بين حين واخر
مفادها اي اتفاق امريكي محتمل مع طهران
بشان البرنامج النووي الايراني لا يكون
ملزما لتل ابيب هذه المسلمه رددها رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو في
اخر مكالمه له مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطوني بلينكن قال له اثناءها ان قناعه
اسرائيل هي ان العوده للاتفاق النوويه مع
ايران لن توقف برنامج شهران قويه واضاف
نتنياهو ان تل ابيب ستفعل كل شيء للدفاع
عن نفسها في اشاره للاحتمالات المستقبليه
التي تنتظر الملف الايراني باوجهه
المتعدده اعود اليك سيد حسين سيد حسين طيب
اشرت الى وجود اكثر من خطه الف وباء وجيم
هل من الان فصاعد ما هو المتوقع وما الذي
يمكن ان يدفع هذا الاتفاق او اي اتفاق
قدما وما الذي يمكن ان يعرقله خاصه في ظل
وجود الموقف الاسرائيلي
يعني اولا
امريكا الان اولويتها حسب ما اعلنت هي
الصين وروسيا من هنا امريكا لا تريد ان
تضيع الكثير من الوقت والجهد باتجاه ايران
وهي بحاجه الى تنفيس والى تهدئه مع الطرف
الايراني
ايران ايضا عندما يكون الحديث عن حصول
ايران على اموالها المجمده سواء كان في
العراق او في كوريا او في اليابان او في
اوروبا
ترحب باي عوده لهذه الاموال لانها تؤثر
بشكل نفسي اولا وبشكل اقتصادي على
المجتمع في الداخل الايراني
الكيان الصهيوني نعم هو الان يعني اربعه
وخمسه ايام تقريبا هو يطرح وبقوه ان هناك
شيئا ما وراء الكواليس وان اسرائيل ترفض
اي اتفاق ولكن ليس هناك من اتفاق ولا يريد
الطرفان الوصول الى اتفاق هناك
يعني التزامات
معينه يقوم بها الطرفان بشكل طوعي بعيدا
عن اي التزام او توقيع او شيء من هذا
القبيل وفي تصوري ان هذا يهدئ الموقف الذي
تطالب امريكا بالتهدئه طب هل يهدئ الموقف
في الداخل الايراني الافراج عن بعض
الاموال هنالك يعني داخل ايران من يطالب
باتفاق او العوده للاتفاق النووي كما
عهدناه سابقا او لا شيء لا يرضى بحلول
وسطيه الافراج عن هذه الاموال هل يمكن ان
يقنع هذا التيار بالحصول على البعض ان لم
يكن الكل
يعني اولا
منذ الحديث عن عوده الاموال
سعر الدولار الذي كان يساوي الدولار 52
الف تومان نزل الى ما يقارب 46 الف
تومان وهذا يعكس ان في ايران الاخبار
الايجابيه تؤثر على الجانب الاقتصادي بشكل
كبير
ومن هنا هل هذه الاخبار تسر الايرانيين ام
لا طبيعي تسر هل التيارات السياسيه تستطيع
ان تعمل عكس التيار الاجتماعي
وترفض هذه
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
يعني
التزامات في تصوري ان من الصعوبه لدرجه ان
يقوم تيار سياسي
بالاعتراض على عوده الاموال الايرانيه
المجمده
التزامات ايران ايضا هي ليست التزامات
تجعل الاطراف المتشدده ان تكون لها رده
فعل كبيره تجاه هذه الامور من هنا نحن
يعني الخطه جيم
اتصور انها هي خطه متدرجه
ليست فيها طفرات في السلوك السياسي وهي
تسمح بانفراجات من دون ردود فعل داخليه او
دوليه طيب سيد جازف ما هي القنوات القادمه
المتوقعه اشار السيد حسين الى ما سماها
التزامات وليس اتفاق من الان فصاعدا وفي
ظل تكرار الموقف الاسرائيلي ما هو المتوقع
اعتقد السيد حسين اثار نقطه مهمه للغايه
لانه من الناحيه السياسيه
وعلى كلا الصعيدان واشنطن وطهران
اتفاق والعوده الى اتفاقنا هو امر بعيد
المنال الان لكن هذه الخطوات الصغيره تكون
بمثابه تكسير للهوات قليلا قليلا هذا
تحدثت عنه مثلا هل ستعطى كوريا الجنوبيه
الموافقه على اطلاق الاموال المجمد لديها
اطلاق سراح السجناء في الشهر الماضي ايران
اطلق الصراحه ثلاثه من المعتقلين لديها
ولو اطلقت ايران سراح بعض الامريكيين هذا
سيكون شوطا بعيدا على طريق التوصل لا
تفاهمات
ربما المزيد من الدبلوماسيه المكوكيه من
عمان فهي طبعا علينا ان نراقبهم فهم
يقومون دور كبير من وراء الكواليس ايضا هل
ستكون هناك اتفاقات مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه هناك قضايا عالقه اذا ما تم
حلها ستزيل كثيرا من العراقيل هل بتقديرك
ستعطي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الضوء
الاخضر للافراج على هذه الاموال لكوريا
الجنوبيه ولغيرها
حقيقه ولكن نحن لا نعلم ماذا يدور وراء
الكواليس وانا اتفق مع زميلي من طهران ان
الامر يبدو وكان هناك خطوات متدرجه
تدريجيه خطوات صغيره ربما سويه قد تشكل
اتفاقا كبيرا لكن ما زال كل شيء في مراحله
المبكره والامر يعتمد على هناك كثير من
المتشددين في ايران الذين لا يريدون اي
انفراج مع الولايات المتحده لهذا السبب
نرى التقدم الحاصل البطيء جدا طيب سيد
حسين الا يمكن ان تؤدي هذه الخطوات
المتدرجه الى جدول اعمال الى خطه متكامله
خاصه ونحن على اعتاب يعني سنه ونصف باقي
على
بقاء الرئيس بايدن في سده الرئاسه في
ولايته الاولى
يعني في تصور هذه الخطوات البسيطه
ولكن المهمه
ستتلاحق
نجاح الخطوات الاولى من دون شك هي ستؤدي
الى سرعه في الخطوات الاخرى يعني
اليوم المكالمه التي جرت بين السيد رئيسي
والسيد مكرون هي ضمن هذا الاطار هناك
اطراف اخرى الوسطاء عمان تقوم بدور كبير
ولكن هناك قنوات متعدده في هذا الاطار
وكلها هي ضمن هذا الاتجاه في ضبط الخطوات
المتقابله بين الطرفين في المجالات
المختلفه شكرا لك سيد حسين رويوران البحث
المتخصص في القضايا الاقليميه
والاستراتيجيه ومن واشنطن جوزيف 7سوني
يعضوا سابق بالمجلس الاستشاري لوزير
الخارجات الامريكيه وكبير الباحثين في
معهد كوينسي الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]